hello everybody markiplier here
welcoming you back to SCP containment
breach okay
got our ultimate keycard ultimate super
mega awesome keycard um come from I'm
actually kind of turned around a bit
think I need to go down here I don't
know no no it can't be right
no no it's not right at all
I think I'm looking for the old man cuz
I need to get the code from his realm
and then I need to find the maintenance
tunnel and I don't remember exactly
where the wing where is it I don't
remember I don't even know if I saw it
in this playthrough I completely forget
hello is anybody out there ah crap ah
alright
let's go hurry up where you out there
yeah I got my way get out of my way
ah ah ha ha ha gasps mast it doesn't let
me run out of stamina like a mouse it's
dark
alright carrying on again I don't
remember a thumb go in the correct
direction I don't think I am because I
know this is my disc back at the
beginning oh damn it ah crap what's that
again end with this
ah you spilled everybody
probably give me I got my super mask
like oh it's okay it must be this way
I'm an idiot I could have saved a bunch
of time yeah oh come on it's ah how is
it even possible there is no exit oh
come on why do I gotta get the Bad Seeds
ah did I know that in the last episode
fear has kind of clouded my mind damn it
what damn it yeah let's see if you want
to Susan your bag this was such a good
play through - oh I am highly
disappointed Balzac ball sack alright I
guess I'm just wasting time now Raj hang
on I got a double check maybe there's
like something I miss no I don't know I
don't know
I don't know Oh why's it got to be like
this why you gotta be like this
why Wow
yeah there's nothing else there's no
other door leads from here there's no
other way out there is nothing oh man I
thought that that was the one NHL all
right
blah blah I'll use your if you if you if
you so keen on NHL I'm not a hockey fan
myself but ok here we go can't believe
it I can't believe it ah I gotta start
again
I'm never gonna be this game at this
rate did I mention I don't like I mean
no I like this game it's very very well
done that's good stopped
maybe this ain't so bad oh I guess right
off the bat another another level too
hard I'll like it unless somehow this is
an exact carbon copy of this seems like
an exact carbon copy of the seed I just
had it does indeed seem like that oh
wait is there going to be a gas chamber
oh there is oh how strange that was
close I almost died okay try that again
oh hi um guy you want to get out of that
doorway thank you are you gonna move are
you gonna move friend oh stop you're not
a - all right - come haha damn it blah
blah blah random seed oh man I I know
what I need to do to beat the game I
know it I know what I need to do she's
not happening
bear the sight is experiencing multiple
youth Euclidean ah okay this is
different now oh it's so nicely lit in
here I can drop my guard even for a
second this one's not so nicely lit even
though there are lights oh this looks
fun but maybe there's a maintenance
tunnel nearby oh okay all right give me
that
save that [ __ ] and here we go Oh lovely
lovely indeed lots of offices look at
that oh please yes yes wait it gets like
the Omni I'm just uh there's uh probably
a thingy thingy you know a thing song e
a thing sang e
a bit pooper you know the fling clamp do
dinger this way I can get all my
super-secret ultimate items right away
like Oh
ah yeah boy fix yeah cook cook for me
you machine make a perfect dough yo ah
no no no I forgot that it doesn't always
work out the way it's supposed okay now
oh maybe this means the other better
that's probably what it is I probably
what it is okay save here and huh Biscay
oh one two oh that's me I'm an idiot I'm
an idiot I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I didn't played this game before us I
swear I played this game before okay
here we go and then do very fine
not rough not rough very fun cook cook
you glorious machine give me what I need
to slay my enemies finally back in
business
okay nothing's after me good all right
now get out of here actually not gonna
save after one just in case something
bad happens you know something bad like
something bad always happens huh
I'm just doing this so I can run fast
okay still nothing after me what's this
ah oh I don't think I need to get in
here for anything I don't think so
look I need to be in there for anything
something for something a little better
than that okay okay and now right more
choices a this should be a safe way to
save right
I don't need anything down there move on
I heard that I heard that okay go go go
go yeah oh yeah
come on oh don't be a bug save I hate
when I say that I go through the floor
don't please
oh thank you
okay there no he's not there
ah there you are just like that black
wall thing I don't know what the deal is
with that it was just there yes no no
this is too early I need I need him to
find me first
I need him to find me ah
I need him to find me first I need the
code I need his code before I can block
him out I'm close to the end guys
this is unreal I'm actually close to the
end I got to go find him okay huh blink
blink lick Nikoli oh come on move oh
don't be like this don't be like this
come on maybe if I just go in here for a
bit
hell maybe I can get go in here and let
him find me maybe he'll find me in here
who knows who knows knows these things
who knows come on radical Larry find me
okay that's that's uh
ah where are they are they the name of
their let's go
I'm ready boy Oh Oh what's that
instantaneousness no give me again what
do you think I am an idiot okay up Oh
see you
okay the door is closed
thank you very much ah
is he still in that room good damn
golly okay I don't know how he got me in
here but I'm gonna we gonna just save it
here iPad and actually I am all out of
time man I am getting close I just need
him to find me
I need to ghost realm and then I need to
escape his realm that's all I need to do
I'm all that time now so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye bye